Speaker 1: Speaking of average skill sets,
Mollie Hemingway and Harris Faulkner at Fox
News.
Harris Faulkner not part of the the the infotainment,
the entertainment side of Fox News, but one
of their straight reporters.
Recently.
Bryan Cranston I know this is going to come
out of out of the blue here, but this is what
this is about.
Bryan Cranston recently appeared on Bill Moyers
podcast.
I can't remember the name of it.
Random things or dumb things or bigoted things
or I don't remember the name, but in it they
started talking about CRT because Bill Maher
is now a useful idiot or maybe a willing participant
in moral panic related to critical race theory.
And the conversation started in, and Bryan
Cranston said he thinks that critical race
theory shouldn't be taught to children.
It would be beneficial where Bill Maher took
him to task for that or disagreed at the very
least.
And this conversation between Mollie Hemingway,
a right wing provocateur and Harris Faulkner,
picks up there.
But I wanted to give you the the background
and the context of this clip.
Watch this.
Speaker 2: After Cranston said it ought to
be taught in schools, let's pause there and
just go right back to Molly, if we could,
to get your reaction.
Yeah, well, Bill Maher and Bryan Cranston
had this discussion on a podcast where Cranston
says that we have not done enough to deal
with our history and not enough is being taught.
I think Bryan Cranston should learn his own
history, such as about the Civil War, which
was the bloodiest war that we went through.
All that has been done to deal with the original
sin, as people say, of American slavery.
And we need more history, not the corrupted
false sort of propaganda history that is being
pushed by left wing activists that teaches
hatred of the country.
Well, you and I say this a lot.
We need more information in general on everything
and then let people decide what you know from
everything they learn, how they live their
own lives.
I've always argued the beginning of freedom
is with as much information as a journalist.
We both agree to this as you can possibly
have, so you can make the best decisions.
Mollie Hemingway, a pleasure to have you in
focus today.
Thank you.
Speaker 1: This should be taught at a graduate
level in a in a course on hypocrisy.
One.
I hope that you noted the little chuckle there
as Mollie Hemingway referred to slavery as
our original sin.
You know our original sin.
Chuckle, chuckle.
Nudge, nudge, joke, joke.
It was indeed the original sin of this country.
The enslavement of millions of human beings
for profit sake.
Two.
To make rich white men in this country richer.
Not wider.
That's not possible, but certainly richer.
And for them to laugh it off is disgusting.
But this entire thing about more, we need
more history taught not, but not the woke
history, not CRT history.
We can't teach about Jim Crow.
We can't teach about redlining.
We can't teach about slavery or convict leasing.
Or just the.
The voter suppression.
An oppression of blacks over the course of
the entirety of white man's existence on this
continent.
No, no, no.
That's CRT.
That's dangerous.
But they do.
They say, Oh, more.
Harris Faulkner argues for as much information
as possible, which is in direct contravention
and contradiction of of the point that they're
trying to say that not that history, not the
history that causes people to hate America.
Listen, I love my country.
And because I love my country, I criticize
my country.
I served four years in the United States Marine
Corps because of some level of patriotism,
some love of country.
So critic being critical of one's country.
It's like being critical of your family, your
brother, your mother, your father, your cousin,
your uncle, just because you hate them.
If you have a best friend that does something
that's a little shitty and you criticize them,
you don't hate them.
If you look back on past relationships, I'm
dumbing this down for an audience that doesn't
need it.
But come on.
Molly Hemingway.
Harris Faulkner.
Participants in the whitewashing of the the
stashing away in a cupboard.
The parts of American history that they don't
like that make them uncomfortable.
They're not able to exist in the space that
is that is uncomfortable for them.
And we need to, as a society, create that
space for our children when we teach them
so they can have two conflicting points and
and deal with it.
Yes, you can love your country.
While also acknowledging the wrongs that we've
committed in the past, the sins against our
fellow man.
Because if we don't and we're unable to.
We're far more likely to create those same
mistakes and commit those same sentence.
Get it together.
Fox News.
Once again, I am Jesse Dallimore.
I host the Dallimore Daily on YouTube.
I host a podcast called I Doubt It.
And you can follow me on social media at dallimore
on Instagram, Twitter and TikTok.
I'd love to see you there.